one good morning Millennials welcome
back to the toast the final episode of
the year
hey Jax
how do you turn I'm doing great because
we're together and the brother and I are
here and it's all hands on deck for the
last show of the year I think it was
Janet Jackson who once said Anna will be
together again cause
everywhere I go every smile I see I know
you are there Marshall Anthony that's
how me and Brian say it because Brian's
dog's name is Marshall and oh I don't
know why we call him Marshall Anthony
but that's so cute it's like literally
actually Brian does what you do like
it's Friday he puts Marshall Anthony in
everything they love that for him yeah I
bet now he'll do Dean Kelly Anthony
um even though Anthony's not his middle
or last name it's just I don't actually
don't know why Brian is obsessed with
the name Anthony he puts Anthony in
everything that's like Joey camasta puts
Marie yeah yeah is it Marie or Trish no
he like I think it's two separate things
like he ever gives everyone the middle
name Marie that's funny
um so yeah you heard it right final
episode of the year I had to come down
for it let's take a look at the year at
a glance we shall and I just want to say
because it's the final episode of the
year I'm wearing this sweater that I've
actually had for a while and I
completely forgot about or else I would
have worn it on the day that she passed
but it's this fabulous libertine sweater
so if you don't like it blame libertine
not me with images of the queen and I
thought that you were coming in here
because you have watched Harry and Megan
I have not because I had the longest day
and I'm like not Jackie making a
statement no I didn't think we were
talking about Harry and Megan today
because you didn't watch so then I
thought we would talk about it together
but you're like you know what I don't
know when I'm gonna watch why don't you
just like recap your thoughts on the
show if I knew I was talking about Harry
and Megan today I would not have worn
the sweater because I like imagine just
watching like a clip of whatever my
thoughts are on hiring Megan it's like
where does she stand yeah know what it's
like I wonder if this girl's on team
Royal or team Harry is this girl biased
so I didn't have time to watch it
obviously I was on the plane yesterday
um and I've been seeing so much coming
out of it and like I actually really
enjoyed Parts one two and three like
keep the Magic No I'm like I'm seeing so
much and it's like I feel like it's
really gonna upset me and I think I'm
just gonna stay where I'm at it was so
bad as far as reasons why they left me
have some reasons I don't feel like we
have the reason a lot of it didn't make
sense to me there was like so much
propaganda and just like confusing stuff
and like just like big buzzwords you
know like the misinformation is a is a
global humanitarian crisis that's
literally what Harry said yeah it's like
what are you talking about totally so
I'll talk about my thoughts but anyways
the sweatshirt isn't the sweater is an
aside and actually snitch picked it out
she came to my closet this morning so I
was asking her what to wear and she saw
this photo she's like why don't you wear
that and I was like why don't I wear
that because 2020 you for 2022 for me
was the year of the queen 2022 for me
was the year of the toes I feel like
this was such like not to me not to make
similar everything about us but I feel
like you know this was a really
important year for us I feel like it was
a very transitional Year yes I the
flamingos joined us Jackie and I were
actually invited on um this power
Women's Summit to talk about like the
business of podcasting and it's on
YouTube if you want to watch it it's
like a lot of like business podcasting
stuff and we talked a lot about our
Rebrand and more importantly like your
move and I thought that this was going
to be the year that like the toast like
didn't end but it was the slow March to
the end yeah like the official beginning
of the end yeah
um but I supported you in your decision
of course to move and this move has just
been so revitalizing for our brand for
the podcast lars's party new beginnings
new beginnings and I just feel like this
was a really good year for the toast I
feel like we got so many new toasters we
blew up on Tick Tock I I mean what more
can you ask for than blowing up on Tick
Tock I lost weight I mean oh my God like
what more could you ask for I had a baby
oh right that's great I moved yeah you
would have thought that this year would
have been like
we're working on some other stuff so the
toast like kind of would have taken a
back seat but no no no no no
so I made the journey down I'm so happy
to be here I slept amazing last night
um woke up literally you cannot pull me
out of bed in New York like I will take
a full hour before getting out of bed I
hopped out of bed on my carries awake
and my room is right next to his yeah
but that's the thing about motherhood
like even though I used to hate waking
up like couldn't catch me doing it I
would always be tired like no matter
what time I woke up always miserable
like now when I wake up I'm tired I like
pee and brush my teeth like with my eyes
closed and then once I get into his room
like I'm up and it's a pleasant
experience he's so [ __ ] gorgeous like
I just love living with him I said I'm
like Jackie I think
it would be kind of cool of you and it's
actually kind of not cool that you
haven't I think like obviously I talk
about a lot like having kids is
definitely something I want to do
um in theory Theory like the act of
doing it is just so not on like my list
of things that I want to do like I'm
just I would like the child to be here
and there's literally a child downstairs
and I think the fact that you haven't
even offered to like I don't know maybe
we could do joint custody like I think
it's kind of rude
um he could be your ward because like
you're gonna have more kids and I feel
like you don't like hate the idea of
being pregnant like you should do that
no but it's like not fair of course like
I've just accepted it but it's not fair
like you get to be under your snatchler
journey right and do my surrogate
no I'm nice I'm a good sister I'm not
that good I know actually I was reading
this book
and this guy um I won't say the book but
like they're in love and she has a lot
of fertility issues and like she really
wants to have kids and so she literally
can't and so she like leaves him and
it's so painful and he comes back with
this whole plan and he said my sister
actually she offered to be a surrogate
and I was like oh man couldn't be me
that would literally never be you
I mean actually let's be real never you
don't even want to do it for yourself no
for sure but let's say like years from
now I've done it for myself and like
somebody in the family like needs a
surrogate like I would like I would do
it I would do anything for my family
years from now uh my stuff is done yeah
yes I agree with that yeah like
hopefully nobody else but yeah no I I
would be open to it yeah at that time so
oh my God we haven't even spoken about
how it's our final episode of the Year
we're looking at the toasted lands and
we're ending the the year with such a
sickening guest someone who we've spoke
so highly of on this show and over the
years over the years he's never wavered
never wavered we've been talking about
her a lot with her new reality show
Olivia Culpo joined us she will be um
joining these if you're listening as a
podcast just keep listening it'll be at
the end of the episode if you're
watching on YouTube Olivia joined us via
satellite as well so there's another
video on our channel right after this
one with the Olivia interview and she
looks so stunning it's just Jackson
Claude and Olivia like nothing nothing
new there no we spoke about snitch the
whole time so we had all four sisters
represented yeah we'd love a sister who
works with and respects other sisters it
was a really good interview so be sure
to check that out and we're just going
out on a high and I know everyone's sad
the toast is over what am I gonna do and
that's why patreon exists I can't stress
that point enough yeah I actually am
filming a vlog today with the snatchler
um because she's doing her snatchler
thing and gonna steal all of my clothes
like we're gonna go through my closet
and give her stuff that's just like too
young for me and then I probably won't
ever wear again like a new face of my
life and you guys can come along and
watch me get pillaged by the snapshot
Village and then one of my favorite
things to do is like Mario's like oh I
got some new clothes can I try them on
for you oh yeah and then there will be a
try on watching like a young person with
a near perfect body just try on clothing
is such a delight you would think like
it would make me like
what's the word I'm looking for
you think watching Margo trying clothes
would like make me depressed and like
hate myself but it's actually like the
funnest thing I agree it's just like
she's really like a fit model yeah I
know it's also fun because like you love
the Snapchat it's exciting when people
you love like try on clothes that you
love yeah but it's more so like from an
aesthetic POV like she's so perfect
it's not true she's just in the other
room we should go gather Bachelor
snatchler also speaking of perfect
yesterday we announced our collab with
Spritz Society our toast holiday pack
which is a variety pack two grapefruit
cans two blood orange cans two Pineapple
cans two lemon cans in a toasty package
with a toasty poem it's available at
sports society.com I know a bunch of you
got them yesterday I'm so glad to hear
that but just wanted to remind you if
you go to spritzociety.com the toast
holiday packs are available they make a
great gift for someone and it's a buy
more save more event so if you get two
packs you get free shipping and 10 off
if you get three or more packs you still
get that free shipping but you guys are
getting 25 off so for the toaster in
your life that's a great gift you don't
even have to wrap it because it's
already wrapped with a little bow and
everything and it has all the content
that you need to get through the
holidays a playlist that you can scan on
the bottom a little poem by the streis
Brethren oh and the by the way we didn't
even acknowledge we're like looking at
our monitor in front of us there's like
400 people in this tiny little frame
because Bryce strikes Jax and mclared
letard are here
um and there's really no better way to
send off
into the holiday season and wrap up and
what what has otherwise been an amazing
year yeah
it's been strong it's been good I'm
ready for 23 ready to take it on yeah
but I want to sit in 22 and appreciate
the good times we had asked Olivia Culpo
this and I think we should ask ourselves
the same question what are we toasting
to in the new year what are some things
we want to bring into the new year
Olivia had a great answer well was hers
again well I don't want to spoil it oh
okay okay what was it but remember I was
like couldn't be me oh right right we're
right that's what we say every year
um
2023
I'm pretty happy where I'm at honestly I
know like that's the thing about
resolutions it's like if you work on
yourself all year long which I try to
what's the resolution like more of the
same I guess the resolution should be
like to continue to work on myself yeah
to continue the good work that you're
doing
yeah
go viral and Tick Tock more keep keep on
keeping on keep on keeping on 100 yeah I
agree maybe like visiting your sister
even more even though you did her so
much it's just so fun when you're here
I feel like I visit you so much like I
think what in the time that I've moved I
visited you visited you equal amounts
that you have visited me but it's like
different because when I visit you I
live with you you know I know but it's
easier for one it's easier like you
don't have to like get a hotel you're in
the House
Hotel Harry it's it's insane so the fact
that I visited you as much I know it's
true you should be visiting me more and
I'm not like trying to put pressure I
just love having you I love being here
come more I feel like I come as much as
I can especially given like this that
the latter half of the year was the
busiest six months of my life like
between toast and tour and just work in
general I feel like I made as much time
as possible and now like in the New Year
I've pretty much got nothing going on
except toast and I can do that even
better from here
I'll definitely be here quite a lot now
that there's three nieces and nephews
and it's a winter so it's the best time
to be here and not there that's true so
I feel like that's the resolution spend
as much time together as we as we can
works for me great and um we've got a
great show I'm doing stories again I'm
doing ads again we're gonna talk uh
we'll recap a little bit of Harry and
Megan because honestly like I said I
don't know if I have the stomach for it
and you already watched it I don't think
that you should I think you should say
where you are with like how much you
like them this is like Blissful
ignorance yeah there's like positives
and negatives to My overall thoughts
about them like and the positives are
still that like their relationship is
Rock Solid and these two people and I
feel like a lot of people are like well
if you didn't want to be a princess you
shouldn't have married a prince
they were never not getting like they
are meant to be together so they had to
figure out a way to be together I'll
talk about all of it in uh and we have a
story about story okay great we've got
some good stories
excuse me I'm getting sick my body's
shutting down because it's like please
don't end the toast you want to go eat
more my body's like oh my God I'm gonna
wake up tomorrow and we're not gonna
toast yeah Saturday shut up my body is
protesting your body's just a workaholic
I speaking of protests I don't know how
that's a segue but I did make it to
season five last night of Yellowstone so
I'm officially like caught up oh cool so
you can watch this weekend and in the
new year we'll have a great big recap
then you should watch 1883. I plan on it
I need to finish 1883 so then I can
watch 1923 and then you said what did
you tell me last night
that this oh this this is crazy because
I remember she said she really loved
Jimmy even though to me he's like so
irrelevant whatever and I was like oh so
season five Jimmy went to the sixes she
was like yeah and I was like it's gonna
be a show and she was like huh so the
sixes is their own show and I like that
yeah so that's what they were doing
there and I just realized that that
horse Wrangler guy Travis is Taylor
Sheridan Sheridan cute because like this
guy look so like familiar and I just
Googled him and it was like his name is
Taylor Sheridan I'm like oh my God I
love that from the commercials like he's
always in you don't watch with
commercials but he's always in the
commercials like talking about
Yellowstone oh oh wow I'm like he does
commercials how did he get this job
um so it's been a really fun Journey and
so was this year and I think there's no
time like the present honestly to just
dri to get right into it it's a dri
Dive Right In to the fast five stories
that you need to know before you finish
out your year tier
but
mcclurgia literium yeah before you dive
into these wonderful stories that you've
selected yes I need to let you know that
today's episode is brought to you by
Bare Necessities you guys think about
the favorite bra you have right now
what's so great about it chances are
it's not anything the broad does it's
more the things it doesn't do have weird
gaps show through your t-shirts oof oof
to me because that used to happen to me
dig into your shoulders same thing with
panties you reach for the ones that
don't ride up and don't give you a panty
line your brown underwear should make
your outfit better not worse that's
what's so great about Bare Necessities
it's one of the biggest online intimate
apparel retailers offering over 140 of
the Best Brands all in one place they
put fit and comfort above all else so
they're all about size inclusivity their
band sizes go from 28 to 58 their cup
sizes go to double a to O they go from
extra small to 5xl so it's so many
options finding the right bra isn't
always intuitive so they offer a bra fit
finder quiz right because which one of
those sizes are you the fit finder quiz
will tell you point you in the right
direction in just a few quit Quicks and
clicks
we love Bare Necessities you know what
there are some things in life that you
can really take our recommendation on
and bras and undies are though that this
bra that I'm currently wearing is from
bare necessities and it is
amazing it's my new like under sweater
bra because I don't like when my
I don't need to get so descriptive yeah
yeah like I just like a tighter look
yeah right now get 20 off Bare
Necessities when you go to Bare
necessities.com toast20 and use code
toast20 that's toast 20 at
barenessities.com toast20 to get 20 off
b-a-r-e-n-e-c-e-s-s-i-t-i-e-s.com slash
toast20 and use code toast 20 some
exclusion Supply m-i-s-s-i-s-s-i-p-p-i
you're literally Akila
oh my God speaking of the bee oh today's
episode is also brought to you by
beekeepers beekeepers Naturals has
amazing products to help you and your
immune support and just overall Wellness
that time of year you guys like it's
that time of year to get the propolis
immune support throat spray honestly I
started my cold you guys actually saw
the evolution of my cold this week and
how exciting and how it crept up on me
and it and it went away just as quickly
as it came it never really materialized
into anything big and bad and that's
because I use beekeepers natural to keep
my immunity in check they use propolis
which is made by bees and backed by
science they are also made with clean
ingredients and they're on a mission to
save the bees bees are crucial to our
planet's Health about one-third of our
food supply would be lost if the bees
disappear that's why beekeepers natural
is committed to sustainable beekeeping
and pesticide free products that is so
sweet Justice for the bees it was
another great day of beekeepers natural
today beekeepers Naturals offering you
an exclusive offer go to
beekeepersnatural.com toast or enter
code toast to get 25 off your first
order that's
[Music]
b-e-e-k-e-e-p-e-r-s-n-a-t-u-r-a-l-s.com
slash toast or enter code toast
beekeepers Naturals products are also
available at Target Whole Foods CVS and
Walgreens so you can start feeling
better every day today that propolis
throat spray is no joke I'm like so
prone to strep throat I have the biggest
tonsils I really need to get them taken
out and it really will make a difference
in how you feel and how you recover so
much of what's that word that saying an
ounce of prevention is worth a pound of
cure and this season especially with
everything going on right now you want
to keep your immune system strong and
beekeepers natural those bees are here
for you okay wait I had something I
wanted to tell you and I was going to
tell you before the shows but I actually
I needed to shame you publicly I am
shocked [ __ ]
beyond belief at the state of your
studio I you're such a clean person
there's a lot that goes on in here no I
know I have a studio as well I mean have
you heard of a trash bin it's hard it's
in the other room I'm just yeah
everything serves a purpose no I'm sure
of that but I was just genuinely shocked
walking in this room and that tissue
with lipstick is yours yeah yes okay
that's the only thing that looks like
outright garbage not that big pile of
ads no pile of what is that those are
holiday lights from my like these are my
work supplies what holiday lights do you
need when I did my holiday toes shoe
everything serves a purpose if you want
to shame you want to work shame me sorry
that my studio is not as big as yours
um just I was shocked I'm sorry I was
shocked I was in tears almost I'm a
hard-working Queen what can I say so our
first story of the day is the video that
everyone's talking about is Kourtney
Kardashian and Khloe Kardashian sat down
for this Vanity Fair interview and it
was full of interesting information I
actually took notes on a few things that
shocked me
um but it also
came out around this time that dumois
released this blind about two sisters
from an iconic family who are not
speaking so this video just like
spiraled people into thinking about
what's going on but the story that
everyone's talking about the moment from
this Vanity Fair interview is that Khloe
Kardashian will not let her daughter
true sleep at her sister Courtney's
house so Kourtney Kardashian's house is
off limits when it comes to sleepovers
for Khloe Kardashian's daughter true the
good American founder revealed during
Thursday's episode of vanity Fair's
popular lie detector test web series
that she will never let her
four-year-old daughter spend the night
at the Kardashian Barker household the
pooch founder asked are you ever gonna
let true sleep over at my house and
Chloe responded probably not Courtney
replied by asking if it was because they
have too much fun over there and Chloe
said no I don't think we have enough
time on this show for what the reason is
hmm But then there was another interview
where she said something like about true
being too young for sleepovers which I
get sleepover's at your sister's house
like I don't know she has like older
kids like she might not be able to keep
up with them well no I think and it's
like a rite of passage of your first
sleepover I don't think true is there
yet but there's something beyond that
because she said she would never allow
so I had two thoughts the first was like
maybe Chloe from her own childhood it's
like sleepover trauma like some people
really didn't like sleepovers they had
bad experiences like maybe she doesn't
want to pass that on to true or and
we've spoken about this a lot and I feel
like the Kardashians have spoken about
it too A lot of the girls having like
just fundamental issues with the way
Courtney parents like maybe they just
don't I don't know how much should
happen in one night I know but and they
have staff around yeah I thought that
was interesting yeah but I also I had
written I think I think it's two things
I think like if
true could go on any sleepover in the
world like Chloe went and sent her to
Courtney's for whatever reason maybe she
doesn't like the snacks that she has a
bunch of stuff and two I think Court
Chloe is like anti-sleepover in general
yeah I mean like if it's when I kind of
feel children like they will sleep at
your house like all the time so I can
just sleep in like that's totally like
your house Olivia's House Margaret's
house that's not a sleepover yeah a
sleepover is with you know strangers
yeah I agree and when it comes to
strangers like they can all sleep here
by the way I agree like you cannot sleep
here I'll get some bunk beds I used to
blow up matching sleepovers like yeah
and I couldn't imagine like I know there
were friends of mine who like weren't
allowed and I was like oh my God that
sucks but now I'm like no like crazy I
actually saw um this woman on Tick Tock
who investigates she's a police
detective like uh children's crimes and
she was like here are things I will
never do as a mom as a police detective
who's been investigating children times
and she was like I will never let my
kids have a sleepover
I thought it was really interesting okay
and maybe the end maybe Chloe saw that
Tick Tock maybe and she's just taking it
really seriously some other takeaways I
had from this video
um the first was that I had literally no
idea Chloe's middle name was Alexandra
did you know that no
um the other thing that I found
interesting is that Courtney watches
Yellowstone yes and that um Chloe did
not like her dress Courtney's wedding
dress which like
I appreciated her honestly but it's also
then like I kind of respect her decision
more because like for me like I will
literally not pick a dress for the
opening of an envelope without sending a
picture to you guys and being like sure
are sure sure and Courtney was like so
into it that like even if her sister
said they didn't like it like she still
moved forward with it so at least she
felt pretty yeah apparently they're like
critical of her style right now I feel
like her style is pretty like mellow
like she got really like travesty but
now she's like found a blend of like
yeah you know being like rocker even
when it was really trying to see it
wasn't that bad it's just like it's not
my personal style it's just like more
edgy yeah like I don't know what the
problem is with that no me neither I
thought the video was really cute I like
seeing the sisters do sisters things I
don't know why they did it like what are
they promoting uh Chloe was definitely
out here promoting nerd Tech otd the
over-the-counter I know the prescription
migraine medication commercials that
she's on because the YouTube video
stopped four times with the nerd Tech
otd commercial before during and after I
should ask my doctor about it you should
and get the t under Tech go today I
don't know why they did it either and I
was curious if anyone felt like this
just kind of like weird vibe like
Chloe's usually very
um
I don't know she felt like like she was
feeling like defensive and like a little
standoffish no it was just that Chloe's
usually like very warm and I felt like
it was a little
um stilted yeah yeah what's the opposite
of warm cold yes that's yeah it's the
opposite that's like the vibe I feel
like she wasn't being a classic Chloe
like how she would with a Chris or Kim
yeah because I think that's just her and
Courtney's relationship right now but I
think that they are fine and honestly if
they really had a problem they would not
be doing this video and I thought it was
fun that they were able to laugh at
themselves I thought that they actually
asked some like real questions not just
like stupid stuff yeah but then speaking
of what you just said this is the blind
item that went viral and I feel like
it's if we learned anything last week
from like the Ariel charnis drama is
like just take Anonymous gossip on the
surface like it's not that deep if at
all if at all but the DU mois blind was
two sisters of this iconic family are
not even in contact with each other
anymore you may see them in pictures but
it's purely for show a Reconciliation is
highly unlikely the older one has
basically confirmed the falling out as
well
it makes you think that it's Courtney
and Kim Kim yeah yeah just because
they've always they I just feel like
they are very different they're so
different and I haven't seen them
together in a while but we also haven't
seen them all together I guess since
Thanksgiving they were all together no
and they did just have this Kardashian
Brands like holiday dinner did you say
like the good American teams the skin I
saw a little bit Yeah but I didn't see
who like of all was there yeah but then
other people were saying it could be
Kathy Hilton and Kyle Kyle but like but
something about that didn't feel like it
I wouldn't call it iconic family iconic
with 2ks oh
duh I was like why did the person spell
it like that I'm not okay they need to
go to the spelling bee literally Akila
somebody get Akila
um no it's definitely not it had okay by
the way I didn't even think about the k
thing it's obviously about the
Kardashians but that still doesn't mean
that it's true right
um but I could see it being chemical but
I do feel like Courtney I feel like it
could be Kim and Courtney like because I
feel like Courtney would get really
um defensive of like child exploitation
and be like upset with Kim that she
didn't take a harder stance oh my God
you're so right also I don't know if you
saw but Alexa Demi officially like I saw
what was that two months yeah the job
time took a long time I don't know her
so I I don't like I don't follow her
it's not on me to like hold her
accountable because I never held her
anywhere else oh by the way you're so
right
I could definitely see that being like a
thing
that was just the only thought because
you know what say what you want about
Courtney but like she is scrupled oh
Beyond like a little too screwed no way
and it's just like random some of the
like Hills she'll die on yeah this isn't
a one worth pursuing oh maybe you're a
hundred percent right I don't know
that's just like that's my working my
working Theory but I I'm not saying that
that's what it is our next story is the
Prince Harry and Megan of it all
um one of the pieces that they spoke
about that's really gone viral is how
are you being pictured in the stunned
silence as his brother Williams text
following the explosive Oprah interview
so a stun Prince Harry was filmed
holding an apparently Grim text message
from an older brother Prince William
whom Harry portrayed as a screaming
bully who forced him out of the family
the final episode of Harry and Megan
caught the explosive aftermath of
Harry's damning 21 2021 Oprah Winfrey
interview after which the heir to the
throne William told a reporter I haven't
spoken to him yet but I will do the
Netflix cameras were rolling when
William sent that text message while
Meghan Markle was on the phone with
celebrity pal Tyler Perry while Markle
finished reading out the response of
Queen Elizabeth II to their Winfrey
interview the camera cut to her husband
standing over her wordlessly holding out
his phone for her to read what am I
looking at she asked in seconds later
gasped wow he just got a text from his
brother she explains to
Tyler Perry before hugging her
overwhelmed husband who laments I wish I
knew what to do the docu-series did not
detail what was in the text William was
the focus of many of the most William
was the focus of many of Harry's most
explosive allegations of mistreatment in
the final three episodes the acrimony
started with William apparently breaking
a pack not to let their teams trade
negative press stories about each other
which Harry called heartbreaking okay
let me get into it because I felt like
the whole storyline was fraught with
contradictions and missing pieces so the
big question that I've always had is
like what was so bad that they had to
leave why did they leave and and why did
they do it the way that they did it so
the documentary pretty much says this
there was a period of time before they
left and it was a period where Megan was
pregnant they were on a tour it was a
lot of work and the media had started
being it was weird it was contradictory
the media was like really hard on her
but at the same time they were saying
that Megan was so beloved on the tour it
was like giving Diana they had this
event at Buckingham Palace the whole
family was there
um Megan and Harry even slept over at
the palace that night they were having
breakfast together the next morning just
the two of them and the paper comes out
and Megan's on the cover like she Shine
the brightest out of everyone yikes and
they were like and so you know that the
family doesn't like that so it's like
is it the media doesn't like the media
is too hard on you but they put you on
the cover you're the darling of the
media which one is it and I also felt
like at any given time you could find in
on any day positive headlines about
Megan and Harry and negative headlights
yeah Megan and Harry's and on the same
like day you could find positive man on
the street interviews about Megan and
Harry negative you can find positive
reporters talking about them and they
just like kept inserting clips and
headlines to like fit whatever they were
saying at the time and it just felt like
there was always so much positive and so
much negative that it's like
it was hard to tell what was what anyway
so the media was like really really hard
on her and when she's pregnant it's she
became extremely depressed and so I
think it was a combination of things
based on what they said a lot of things
they spoke very vaguely about but I
think it was like the media scrutiny
scrutiny
um
the job itself when they were living at
their first Cottage it was like small
like it was not fast like the ceilings
were like this she said Oprah came for
tea and she was like if people only knew
yeah it's actually funny very unfabulous
I think and it caused and then all this
stuff like that was going on the media
with her dad and then she said she was
doing one of her walkabouts and one of
the women was like it's terrible the way
you're treating your dad and then that
made her realize like oh people are
really believing some of this stuff
so it's centered like into a a very deep
depression then she gave birth to Archie
and they didn't do the Royal birth
protocol the same way that it's been
done in the past I don't think that she
said at no point Did anyone say like you
can't do it this way but I guess maybe
like the media felt a little burned that
they didn't get those steps pictures I
mean those steps pictures are [ __ ]
insane I know but I feel like I mean
they did have like um Princess Anne was
it or maybe it was Margaret like so
someone who's not in direct line on the
steps but other than that it's Diana
it's Kate and it's Queenie herself like
it's not people right it's fair yeah
like they can do it from the throne room
two days later right that's fine by me
anyways they at the end of 2019 they're
going they went to Vancouver to like
take a break because like Megan needed a
break and all right after Archie's born
after yeah Archie must be six months at
this point because he's born in May and
already like the house is being swarmed
and there's people like it's an island
and there's like boats outside and it's
like crazy Madness so Harry says like
they want to for years they've been
talking about moving outside of the UK
being like half in half out there was a
plan for them to move to New Zealand
that never took off there was a plan for
them to move to South Africa but then it
got leaked and once things get leaked
like it's never going to go through so
they wanted to move to Canada which is
still in the Commonwealth and they still
want to work for the queen so he writes
a letter to his dad like saying we want
to move to Canada like this is our plan
if it doesn't work we will relinquish
our titles okay and
then that letter gets leaked and it's
like so that I think that was the first
I'm trying to like also follow it in the
way that I remember it that was like the
first thing of like Megan and Harry are
stepping down from the family they're
half in half out so then they go to the
UK they have this meeting with the queen
and everyone uh I think only Harry was
there
and they offered five options one option
being like everything stays as it is
like you stay in the family five being
like you have nothing so like a spectrum
a spectrum and he chose number three oh
so somewhere in the middle
um then after that meeting there was a
report in the press that the brothers
that William had bullied Harry out of
the family and up until in the
documentary they never mentioned
anything about William and Kate their
treatment in the family and that being a
reason why Megan was like so unhappy and
why they had to leave ever not once so
I'm here sitting here being like Oh so
that report is like very untrue right
and the royal family is like in a
tailspin right now like two members are
like leaving there's a report that the
Brothers are fighting so they
immediately issue a statement from their
joint office without consulting Harry
saying these reports are untrue like
there's no bad blood between the
brothers and that's when Harry says wow
they were willing to lie for William but
they never were willing to tell the
truth to protect us so it's like I
understand that frustration it's like
all this time with all the stories about
Tom it's like Megan could never say
anything they can never tell they're
right no that's frustrating but in five
seconds they'll put out this
quote-unquote lie to protect William but
that's not to protect William it's to
protect everyone everyone like they're
in free fault right and according to
what I've been watching this whole time
William was never will bully you out of
the family you've never spoken about him
you know what if the reason why you guys
were so unhappy If part of that had to
do with like William and cage treatment
and you're sitting down to do a
documentary like say it because then
don't say that them putting out that
Seaman was a lie because I'm saying they
were saying where's the lie no the only
thing they said even in the first part
it's like the first time they met it was
like a little formal yes that's all they
said it so then after they put out that
statement like Megan and Harry were
flabbergasted that they would run so
quickly to Williams defense it's a kind
of an overreaction and they went AWOL
like they oh that was that was it like
that's what sent them yep that was what
sent them over the edge and they said
we're leaving the family
um they you know they were in Canada
they're packing up their things can I
say something
I feel like when they were in it and
like they had a baby and they were like
very anxious and she was dealing with
you know mental health like I feel like
perhaps
they
not overreacted but like
maybe overreacted and now they're like
trying to justify like now when you look
back in hindsight you think like oh was
it that bad but like when you're in it
it's like oh my God we have to get out
of this situation right because you
never like I think for Harry and
everything really is I think Harry's
doing doing
um because he's the only one really who
has the
uh like he's the only one who could make
these decisions like I think he would
never have done it without Megan like
she showed him that he could do it but
it really kind of now looking back like
feels like he always had one foot out
the door and I never realized like how
much trauma he has from childhood
everything comes from Diana like really
and I think with everything every day
with Megan and everything that happens
to her he just sees it through the
letter of like how it could end up like
Diana and so he when he sees like
something's like going badly and Megan's
not doing well he's like I'm removing my
family from this no and you know what
Megan was like like you know I'm sure
the psychiatrist would diagnose it but
he's trying to be the person that like
he wishes his mom had yes no and
honestly Megan's mental health and like
her depression and I know she had
Suicidal Thoughts like that's reason
enough like they should have left yeah
but I don't know why on the way out and
now even they feel the need to burn
everything to the ground so here's the
thing so they left remember and I feel
like everyone was pretty I mean
obviously there's always people who are
not but on the whole pretty respectful
like the queen was still like their
doing what's best for them I'm sure that
you know everyone the family behind
their door behind closed doors were
pissed but like everyone was still
acting right and like this is a okay
happy family thing
things went South at the Oprah interview
yeah that's what changed everything and
they spoke about it a little bit but I
think and I think that they should I
think they have regret also the Oprah
interview talked about a lot of things
and Megan said she was like I thought
the big takeaway from the old Oprah
interview would be like my mental health
right no it wasn't it was the race yeah
and then in this documentary they didn't
mention that comment again they didn't
mention like any uh racist actions or
from the feelings from the family like
there was nothing about the family so
except the approach but that was an
irrelevant public family yeah the core
yeah so
it kind of was telling a different story
than the Oprah interview and it kind of
felt like they were backtracking a
little bit um I think that the Oprah
interview like that severed things and
that's when William sent that text yes
of course they had just left and did
what was best for themselves and their
family and their mental health which at
that point like I understand of course
because they were being like swarmed and
it's just not easy and you have a new
baby and you're so anxious if we're
never gonna sit on the throne then for
what what are we working for what for
what I agree like I I get it now and the
Oprah interview changed everything yeah
of course and I just feel like this
story is actually really emblematic this
New York Post story I just read is very
emblematic of like their Vibe it's like
throwing out like a grenade like look at
this text and then not telling us what
it is so it's like we have to imagine I
just feel like they're kind of always
like saying big things and not backing
it up like even again you watch this
whole six-part documentary and you are
not entirely sure what the reason was
that they left yes also a big reason of
why they left was
um this suit with the Daily Mail so yeah
the Daily Mail printed a letter that
Megan wrote to Thomas Markle at the
advice of the queen and Prince Charles
like she she went to the queen like what
did I do everyone said write him a
letter she wrote him a letter
um she sent it to her Asian and lla made
sure the agent got it to him and he sent
gave it to the Press of course she said
that the signature on delivery was not
Thomas's signature so it's obviously
someone else
um
and then the Daily Mail published a
letter A lot of it is redacted
and you you they showed us one redacted
line and it's just I wish for nothing
but peace and for you to be well sure it
was a nice letter it was a nice letter
but it's such an invasion of privacy I'd
love to have seen all the other
reactions but they're saying like
anything that they redacted was things
that would have made Megan look better
anyways you're not allowed to publish a
letter like that so Megan sued good but
for a while she went to the first the
lawyer at within the palace and she was
like we're gonna Sue and they were like
great and like nothing happened and then
eventually they went and sought outside
counsel and they sued and I think they
said it too like that was the first time
that they stepped outside the bounds of
the firm right like once you're starting
to get your own lawyers like then what
about in our own house no totally
totally so she never had support in her
suit the suit like went on for years she
eventually won and she won on appeal did
Camilla and Charles sue the publication
that ran that phone call of theirs
because to me that's where my mind goes
and it sounds like her letter she made
her look good it's still an invasion of
privacy I don't think that they did and
that's what the everyone said it's like
well we didn't even Sue when this
happened we don't we don't yeah we
didn't we don't because this they have
this relationship no it's it's the
relationship but it's also this thinking
that like we pay for your life and this
is the price that you pay us it which is
like
a
you open up your whole world to us
that's why we want to see your baby when
it's born that's the right that we have
yeah no I get it it's a little extreme
like I do think you know they're not
like animals at the zoo no and even
public people whose lives are paid for
by the tax are entitled to a modicum of
privacy like I don't I don't subscribe
to that notion and you know what if it's
not my tax dollars but if it was I would
say you know what I'll see your baby in
two weeks go take a nap yeah totally so
I think it's it's become a little
extreme but I also think for centuries
the crown has had a relationship with
the media yeah but the media has never
been as like invasive as it is now you
know ever it used to be there was a
newspaper and we have to fill the page
there was one now it's like we have
unlimited pages on our website we have
unlimited places for ads unlimited
Publications as many stories and then
there's social media and like there's
just it never ends yeah no it never ends
so the contract like isn't working no
it's a modern era no and it's it doesn't
make sense why they have this like toxic
relationship yeah with the British
tabloids and it's like not even like
like okay you want to have like okay you
in British Vogue sure but like the sun
yeah it's like so tacky yeah I do think
that the family like should probably
rethink but I would love to hear from
them why what the value is I'm sure
they've they've evaluated I also would
love to know how much of taxpayer money
goes towards the royal family in a year
and how much money the royal family
brings in in Revenue in a year so they
bring in more than they spend which is
why they're still around because if the
country was like losing hundreds of
millions of dollars every year they
bring in a [ __ ] ton of money all the
Palaces the tours the tourism I don't
know the numbers exactly but I do
believe they're in the green that's
great so maybe since like I mean this is
for them to decide but I wonder why they
don't go private they say like you keep
your taxpayer money we'll pay for our
life but we're also going to keep all
the money that we bring in
but then are they still Royals
yeah I think then they're just like a
rich family
yeah then it like downgrades them one
step further right but I think they're
still Royals but it's like you know
don't worry don't pay for us right I
mean they have a lot of money they have
a lot of money and they bring in a lot
of money and then if they didn't have to
like rely on the taxpayers they could
write books right yeah they could bring
in more money but then they're not like
civil servants
no but they could still be civil
servants but then it's like they're it's
like a charity no but I think like the
actual term civil servant means like
like a politician is a civil servant
because his salary is paid for by
taxpayers yeah well they could have a
salary but like you know what I mean I
just yeah I wonder what that the
argument is against that I just think
they think in the comments please they
think it's like a step down yes and it
would be like one step further towards
the end of The 100 monarchy but like
this is not sustainable it ain't
yet William and Kate and Charles and
Camilla like seem okay with it yeah I
mean Charles like and Camilla like went
through it no I think it's almost like
nobody cares it's a matter of hiding it
better I think the job is really hard no
matter who you are yeah and they're
really fun parts of it and they're
really horrible parts of it so it'll be
really interesting when like George gets
married right
right so
I thought that it was
um confusing still and I think the Oprah
interview while when it first came out
was a bombshell was a bombshell and
everybody Beyonce texted her
um I think it caused irreparable damage
with the family I don't know how much it
changed hearts and minds I think that
they did it she said she said they did
it because of everything that had
happened that year and I think she meant
more so about what everyone was saying
about them that year like they left the
family and so she wanted to like clear
the air but I think it just gave more
air to you know if you want to go and be
private and live your life go for it go
for it but
it's
it's
uncouth to trash the whole family agreed
and the whole country and the whole
system no honestly I don't think I'm
gonna watch it and also I feel like I
just watched it and then they had this
whole thing about like hate the trolling
and the hate that Megan was getting and
it was so confusing they had this agency
that like evaluated 114 000 of the
tweets about Megan just a pool of tweets
70 of them were hate tweets and of that
70 they were only coming from 80
accounts like 80 troll accounts and then
they said that um it's all like house
like white housewives these 80 women and
one of them is Samantha Markle dead and
it's just like okay so ahead of all the
hate that Megan gets like it's 80 people
fabulous but I didn't understand what
what point they were why they're sharing
that I think that that's the good news
yeah
and then you can like block those 80
accounts and they were like troll Bots
right right why is Megan worried about
Bots like no that's weird it was really
that there was like a whole section of
that it was really [ __ ] weird and it
was like this weird
um data agency that like places like
misinformation I'm just like the [ __ ] is
this no that's beyond confusing
um well thank you for your thoughts I
appreciate you and let's move on to some
chrisly news because the overall they
seems so happy yeah and the they just
are home in Montecito with Megan Harry
Megan's mom and the kids and the two
kids and the two dogs fabulous it seems
like that's all they've ever wanted so I
hope they're happy it's the one you got
yeah I hope they're happy it looks like
like just a peaceful idyllic idyllic
family life so I guess that's that on
that
um so there's a lot of like uh custody
drama going on with the Chrisleys
because Chloe's biological mom has
entered the chat so do you know who
Chloe is okay so the Chrisleys have a
bunch of kids and their oldest son
has a daughter her name is Chloe and for
the last couple of years Todd and Julie
have been raising her the mother has
like really never been in the picture
but now she's wanting in because todded
Julia Julie are going to prison so
prison bound Todd Chrisley emphasized
that his adopted daughter oh so they
adopted her his adopted daughter Chloe's
biological mother surrendered her rights
to the 10 year old and should not regain
custody he said it's ironic that her
biological mother would come forward now
that she has not been in her life since
2015 and Angela Johnson surrendered her
parental rights in March of 2017 and we
never heard from her again he said that
on a podcast the former Chrisley Knows
Best star explained that he and his wife
Julie Chrisley legally adopted Chloe so
it's up to them to decide who gets
custody of Chloe after they begin their
Collective 19-year prison sentences
he continued we're not going to discuss
what who that's going to be because we
don't owe that to the world and that's
our private matter at the end of the day
Chloe's family is who Chloe has been
raised with her life is going to be as
unaltered as it is as it possibly can be
on what Julie and I have the ability to
control Todd continued to go off on
Johnson for legally giving up her
parental rights to the child asserting
that she has no more rights to Chloe
than a stranger on the street does
Angela Johnson literally surrendered her
rights to the child she did this in
front of a judge the judge explained to
her you understand what you're doing you
understand that you're surrendering the
rights to your child Todd recalled
adding that Johnson denied in court that
anyone promised her anything Financial
nor had anyone threatened her
just so the record is very very clear
Angela Johnson has no rights to Chloe
her rights were terminated she has been
legally adopted but ever since
the sentencing came out she now wants
custody back but like who will get
custody of Chloe what about the dad
yes he's troubled
their eldest son has was on the show in
the beginning then when M.I.A he's
definitely troubled I think he struggles
with like some substance abuse do you
think that the Chrisleys could serve
separately
since they are parents technically I
mean technically they can but then
they'll never see each other again yeah
you know yeah I mean Savannah is
somewhat of age Chase is so much
somewhat of age and their eldest
daughter who has children Probably
sounds like the best option but like she
has a very complicated relationship with
the family she's like spoken out about
them and then they were wrong at terms
and then she's spoken out again so she
seems like the perfect person because
she actually seems like she has her head
screwed on straight
um but I don't know like what do you
what do you do with
Chloe I don't know it's really sad yeah
hopefully like someone
I mean it sounds like her mom is
stepping up but it's not that easy no
one I don't even know if I would like
feel good about leaving even it is her
biological mom but like she literally
gave her up yeah
how old is Chloe again she is
she's mad cute
she is I think 10.
damn technically like one of her
siblings or like half siblings you know
yeah I think Chase
if I recall I think maybe he's engaged
so like someone who's like settling down
Savannah is settled I think there's like
a decent amount of options but they're
young Lindsay the the daughter is the
best option but I don't know what her
relationship is currently like because
who lives the closest to the Chris like
where the Chrisleys live that way she
doesn't have to like go to the same
school and stuff yeah I don't know
this is really sad the Chrisley thing
like the more I think about it is like
so crazy so it's like a really long
sentence for a non-violent crime
yeah that's really sad
um our fourth story
is crazy is it the crazy fourth story
that's brought to you by Origins it is
that's such a weird coincidence I know
well that's because Origins is the
pioneering nature infused skincare brand
that has elevated gift sets that will
surprise and Delight everyone on your
holiday shopping list they will surprise
and Delight delightfully talented
Origins creates transformative skincare
with naturally derived ingredients to
noticeably improve how skin looks and
feels argents has a history of
commitment to our planet by reducing
waste and caring for our natural
resources all of origin's holiday gift
card sets are plastic free recyclable
and sourced from responsibly managed
forests and for every tree harvested new
trees are planted to date the brand has
planted over 2 million trees around the
world so you can feel good about the
gifts you are giving this season from
Origins you're giving the gift of trees
as well as the gift of wonderful skin
care of course as Gia judice once said
it's a season of Joy it's a season of
trees Origins has amazing amazing sets
that you can get they do do you want to
hear about them I would love to they
have the best seller set which is the
Fantastic favorites six best-selling
essentials from cleanser to moisturizer
size to go wherever the holiday takes
you which is like is it going to take
you to your sister's house it might
[ __ ] should it should I'm sorry if so
you can stuff those stockings with
Origins it freaking shouldn't they have
the mask this way which is a five mask
starter kit the masked starter
similar to The Masked Singer but it's
just for using in your bedroom around
the holidays and bringing 72-hour
hydration then they have all for use
which is a plant scription Essentials to
cleanse and pump and they have their
all-time Essentials which are their
favorites to brighten refine renew and
rejuvenate
get Origins gift sets today available at
origins.com
also I have to let you know that today's
episode is also brought to you by diff
eyewear oh stunning some people ask me
how I can be so positive all the time
and it's because I'm blocking out the
haters with diff eyewear no for me like
I'm blocking out toxins I'm blocking out
toxic people I'm blocking out negativity
I'm blocking out haters and I'm doing it
with diff eyewear which is stunning well
made and affordable stunning sunglasses
and just eyewear in general I love the
little Luxe touch in my life and this is
somewhere around you're literally more
around
are you like I love a little Luxe touch
in my life and if buyware helps hit that
spot whenever I want to embrace some
seriously Deluxe celeb energy I pop on a
pair of sunnies from this Luxury iconica
Line The iconica Collection is super
elevated all premium and total Modern
Luxury Vibe featuring six Styles in
multiple colorways these details are the
definition of contempt very he I just
got a bunch for my trip to Belize and
they're so believed yeah I'm going on
vacation and I'm bringing my deaf
eyewears with me because you know what I
don't want more wrinkles I know I'm just
like walking out the sun no I'm gonna
talk about the number one hater the sun
I'm gonna be outside all day we have
like a booze cruise we have a scent we
have like a million things planned and I
just want to have like glasses that I
can like they're durable like I don't
have to be we're so concerned about them
jump in the water we jump in the water
exactly yep the holiday shipping cutoff
is only a few days away but there's
still time to shop for Chic shades for
everyone on your list best of all only
on the toast can you score an extra ten
dollars off right now this is an iconica
worthy exclusive offer just for our
loyal toasters of course use code toast
at checkout now for an additional ten
dollars off your offer ten dollars off
your order so hurry on over to
diffeyware.com to wrap up your Luxe
holiday shopping and again you get 10
off with code toast or you can even gift
yourself a little something iconica for
50 off and don't forget to visit
diffeyware.com toast for a chance to win
one thousand dollars cash and if Sunny's
for a year damn
um okay so earlier in the week we were
talking about the crazy news that
Janelle from Sister Wives left yes the
family yes we were and then yesterday
Mary Brown confirms her 32-year marriage
to Cody is over she says he made the
decision
it's over for Mary and Cody Brown in
people's exclusive look at the first
Sister Wives one-on-one episode airing
Sunday Mary confirms that her 32 year
32-year marriage to Cody 53 has ended
during her conversation with host
sukanya Krishnan Mary watches a clip of
Cody saying he doesn't consider himself
married to her he said if she wanted to
move on and marry another she wouldn't
get an argument with me he tells cameras
in a confessional sukanya then asks Mary
how it makes her feel to hear those
words from her husband she said it just
doesn't make sense to me that he would
be so frustrated with Christine and be
like she made this decision we didn't
consult we didn't talk she just made the
decision to leave and then he says no I
don't consider myself married to Mary
like he just made the decision I've
never heard him say that to me Christine
and Cody announced their split in
November of 2021 so there's a lot of
interesting things going on here the
first is that
one there's only one wife left and I
literally my wife stand and I feel like
every time we talk about them I say how
he's totally in love with Robin and it
feels like everything he's done in this
last year has been to just be alone with
Robin the crazy coveted protocols like
pushing people away pushing Mary away
and Mary like he was you know that he
had to legally Mary was his first wife
and I always say whenever I'm talking
about them like she's the most desperate
and he was the only one who he was she
was the only one who he was legally
married to like they were married in
faith to the others but you can only be
married to one person in this country
and he divorced Mary said he could
legally marry Robin the new one so it
was like he's just like Time After Time
treated Mary so poorly Mary also went
through this like weird Scandal where
she was like catfishing someone like she
was a unique girl like she was going
through a lot
um so after all of that he's still the
one divorcing her like leaving her
because they weren't even technically
married yeah and now he's alone with
Robin which is all that he wanted and my
question is where do we go from here on
the show sister wife
maybe I mean it sounds to me like this
man can't be happy with one woman and so
he's gonna get sick of Robin he's gonna
have a new hot thing yeah then it's the
cycle begins again Robin will be the new
Mary Robin
That's so well put also I didn't watch I
don't watch any anymore but this most
recent season like apparently he was
awful to her like saying the most mean
things about her in his confessionals to
the other wives and so I think a lot of
people saw this divorce and was like oh
good she saw what he said this season
and left like she still didn't leave he
left her
oh my God like it's so
sorry it's pathetic
yeah
regardless she's out
everyone's out force her
what's so crazy though is that like
they're this big blended family they
have a million kids and like them
breaking up like because they're not
legally married like all the women like
it literally takes a day like marriages
end in years because of divorce is a
divorce right and like when they liked
each other I don't know how you split up
a house or anything like that when
you're not legally married and he's not
legally married to any of them now
except for Robin it's whoever's name the
house is in I bet it's in his he's a
prick
hmm it's just it's an interesting type
of divorce when literally none of these
people are actually married I'm sure
that's what will be on the show oh I
would like to see a show with the new
ladies like re-adjusting to normal life
I wonder if they're going to enter into
like obviously they're going to date and
stuff but do they plan on entering into
polygamous marriages again
like I wonder what their POV on this
experience was like would recommend or
would not recommend depends on the man
Cody is the man and I don't think anyone
would ever want to be married to him
ever again I just can't believe like I
started watching Sister Wives in high
school and the second I saw Robin I knew
I knew I hate to be right you know it's
like the time I saw a little mix perform
and I literally said they're gonna break
up and it's going to be just stories and
into my list of stories because I saw
them perform in like a really small
intimate concert I was I was like an
intern and I said I literally said it to
you I said Jesse's gonna be the problem
and this band is going to break up and
that's exactly what happened sometimes
I'm Clairvoyant and then sometimes I'm
totally off totally where's this
Claudia's repeated stories there Little
Mix that's definitely one of them oh my
God there's so many so many there are if
there's so many maybe there are none
so I am a Storyteller it's what I do for
a living I'm a Storyteller our the final
story is some casting news because where
the Crawdad sings star Daisy Edgar Jones
has been cast to play Carole King in the
adaptation of the Broadway play about
Carole King called beautiful and people
are like a little like upset about it so
Daisy Acker Jones is going from where
the Crawdad sing to singing is Carol's
King that is a mouthful the actress
who's 24 oh my God I don't know why I
thought she was older has been cast to
play Carole King in an upcoming film
adaptation of the Broadway musical
beautiful from Sony variety reported
Thursday it'll be directed by Lisa cholo
Danko who made 2010s uh the 2010 movie
kids are all right so people are upset
because
Daisy Edgar Jones is not Jewish and
Carol King is like notably Jewish she I
didn't know she was Jewish but I also
like don't know her by the way I took
the words right out of my mouth like I I
believe that she's Jewish and I believe
she's like an iconic Jewish woman when I
tell you I have literally no idea who
she is like there's that song you gotta
get
from the commercials like
I don't know it well enough no the one
that I think I know is I think and tell
me if I'm wrong but I think Taylor Swift
performed at her Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame induction ceremony and saying will
you still love me
tomorrow
that sounds like Carol King from what
I've seen from the same piano Vibes no
it's like you gotta get on off your feet
that's the one okay
Carol King's Song I'll go to Spotify
like what does she sing that's an
amazing question maybe then you've got a
friend in me okay also where you lead I
think that's the one I just sang by
Taylor Swift okay oh no
or is that get on your feet will you
love me tomorrow that's the one that
Taylor's saying
I think she's also really um famous as
being a songwriter not even a performer
because she's she wrote chains which
chains excuse me which is a um Fleetwood
Mac song got it okay the song that I'm
singing is I feel the earth move and
that's from the beautiful commercials
for the play yeah and then you gotta get
on off here that's from that yeah yeah
so she's definitely a legend she's just
not anything like um
that we're super familiar and so even
though I typically am like a Jews should
play a Jews considering I did not know
she was a Jew as I can't be that mad
considering Jenny that she was a U.S I
don't [ __ ] care how about that let me
but now my thing is do they [ __ ] look
alike no well actually what did a young
Carole King look like the thing is it's
like I want to know who is managing
Daisy Edgar Jones and I would like to
become a client of theirs because she's
undeniably talented but I feel like she
popped on the scene and she got like
three times in a row like the most
sought after roles she got um normal
people which like the book had such a
cult following then she got crawdads the
book had such a cult following now she
got beautiful Carol King which is
definitely like a really prestigious
role definitely a role a lot of people
want especially actors I can see it I
could see it especially girls who sing
so I just feel like does she sing right
I don't know how she keeps getting these
roles but like I need her manager I
actually think she looks like her with
like when she has a wig on I'm sure
she'll do a great job and I also just
get confused because her name is Daisy
Edgar Jones and she keeps playing the
characters from books but she's not
playing daisy Jones in the adaptation
correct yes it's Riley Keough and we
actually just got the first trailer for
Daisy Jones in the 60. you see it no we
also got a trailer for Barbie officially
it just came out today but I hate making
a story a trailer yeah no I know um but
Daisy Jones in six is like on its way
yeah it's a TV show though not a yeah
movie correct
yeah we were talking about that at book
club like things that have been adapted
into movies like how they take so long
because
um we we have it ends with us take
longer
we have It Happened One Summer
oh we were talking about Eliza starts a
rumor at my book club because it's
really the perfect just got picked up
just got picked up for a show on peacock
which I actually think it's the perfect
book for a TV show agreed
um but these things take so long yeah
Rhys gets him out pretty quickly though
Rhys is a machine yeah machine
I don't want to end the episode like
it's over that's those are the Fast Five
I know um I could share some more of my
thoughts about Harry and Megan because I
only talked about the part where they
left but I was just I just saw when I
was looking at my notes for your stories
that I had more notes about the show
which was that they started to say that
the brothers offices split up right
before Christmas like they had a
Christmas party planned and that day it
turned into two parties because that day
the office split but why did their
household split right before Christmas
like what happened between context like
this episode this whole show alludes to
the fact that like something must have
happened with the brothers because
where they tell nothing right that's
like that's even emblematic of that
story we wrote here's this text but it
doesn't say what the text is also the
weirdest thing that you're gonna find so
crazy so Megan was getting like a lot of
really bad press and she was really
struggling and her friends were really
worried about her so five of her friends
went to People magazine and did like a
whole interview tell all about like how
amazing Megan is it wound up coming to
bite her in the ass during her Daily
Mail I could have told you that no like
when it came out it was fine whatever
that's a cringe it was so cringe I don't
know if they even told her they were
doing it I imagine that they did because
like if if she found you can't [ __ ]
around like that we can't [ __ ] around
like that but then in the Daily Mail
suit it became a problem because in that
article they they talked about that she
wrote a letter to her dad and that just
became like some sort of like press
thing
um like making it like public right
right right oh my God but I was like
these [ __ ] friends like how is that
gonna help anything you know what I did
wonder I wondered what their
relationship and I'm curious if they
mentioned it is like now with Eugenie
and Jack because I felt like they were
really close they never mentioned them
I'm curious especially at the beginning
I feel like they really helped them like
I'm curious too and I feel like they
have a lot of mutual friends and like
like this to do the same stuff and I
feel like be friends Eugenie and Jack's
level of like Royal is exactly what
Harry and Megan needed Royals but they
also live in the real world so they get
invited to like all the cool stuff but
they don't have to do a lot of the
[ __ ] and like they very much can
operate like in regular society and I
feel like that's actually like an ideal
and I think like growing up they
probably felt like you know like ugly
stepsisters they were like the cousins
who like didn't get to come to this and
this and now that they like have kids
it's like it's so much more normal it's
still far from normal but like it's more
balanced yeah I wonder if they can still
be friends even though like
you know Eugenie is still working around
yeah no and it's like you insulted Gran
you made Grands a few last years tough
no I think they all probably feel very
defensive overground team Grand yeah but
eugenie's like fabulous I actually
really like her yeah
same
um the Two Sisters yeah what's the other
one's name Beatrice Beatrice actually
which one do I think I guess I'm
confused they look exactly alike I think
they look nothing alike no no they're
twins they're literally crazy except the
crazy thing about them is that their dad
is prince Andrew like we just don't talk
about that you know yeah but like they
didn't do it no 100
um so the episode is not over if you're
listening as a podcast enjoy our
interview with Olivia coppo and if
you're watching on YouTube just head
over to our Channel and it's right
underneath this video
um any final words for the year
oh you know what
Megan um
in the documentary talks about how each
year she like has a word for her year
Okay and like one year it was truth and
then it was peace okay what's your word
for
23.
I feel like this was oh for 23. yeah I
thought we should give our year a word
bro no it's like an aspirational for 23
but you could sum up 22. because I would
sum up 22 as growth oh I have a good
that's good because I feel like I'm
actually like the person I am now is
actually quite different than the person
I was at the beginning of the year I
like that okay
my word for 22 would be roots
Bloom where you planted I'm putting down
Roots I like that like physically
emotionally yeah I love that yep and
then for 2023 what do we want our word
to be yeah what are we aspiring towards
what are we looking to bring in
that's a good question
it's a hard question I don't know I know
I don't know if I continued growth
[Laughter]
um well this has been a great year for
the toast we couldn't have done it
without all the listeners everyone who
watches on YouTube or listens as a
podcast follows us on Instagram we
really appreciate your continued support
we hope the toast has been an important
part of your year whether you just
listen to it while you get ready on your
walks on your way to work or it's
something you really look forward to
when you get home whatever it is we
loved being a part of your year we loved
having you be a part of our year this
show would be absolutely nothing without
you we love all you guys and we hope you
have an amazing break everyone whatever
days you're taking off enjoy them relax
find enjoy you deserve it be with your
family have a couple cocktails just
reset rejuvenate for the New Year we
love you we love you thank you all for
being toasters and for watching along
with us for the great episodes the good
episodes and the sprinkle of
bad ones I can't even think of a bad one
but some are just less good then of
course you know so for the last I really
can't think of a bad one but I'm sure
you guys can so for the last time this
year
oh no strikes don't let her do it thank
you so much for listening to the toast
the Millennium Morning Show where we
deliver the fast five stories and you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so for watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
to give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast and we're
podcasting be found so on Spotify iTunes
ditch Republic video I already guess box
all the boys in a podcast find us the
toast to leave a five-star review about
our beautiful stunning smart and wicked
challenged we are hope you guys have an
amazing New Year amazing Christmas
Kwanzaa Hanukkah we love you dearly love
you darn and if you're already feeling
sad that this show is ending head over
to patreon.com if you subscribe today
you'll have enough episodes that
literally if you started right now and
you watch them all it'll get you to the
new year
um and you'll get the new episodes when
they drop next week
goodbye
[Music]
see you see you in a year
goodbye streisands goodbye
and
that's right toast 2022. we did
it since class of 2022. we we did it
right now
and
I promise I didn't know he was Streisand
I would have noticed a gold wedding band
Streisand
and I'd rather you hate me than not
understand
okay we're done we're done and you know
what you're done